welcome to this video this is the first
video in a series of videos father
Kashima memorial are now being held in
other mahjongg not quite sure about the
precise city it's not even back to west
you would expect it to be yeah this is a
double round-robin tournament six seven
participants the two top players of
azerbaijan ahmadiyya roof and a job of
take part we have steggy coyoacan from
russia
Fabiano Caruana from italy Hikaru
Nakamura from the US and the world
champion among the scars from Norway so
an excellent film guaranteeing
interesting chess this will be ten
rounds and yeah with six participants
double RonRon it's clear to attend
rounds and I would do coverage of this
tournament in a game of the day format
for the candidates tournament I did I
did very very extensive coverage with a
couple of hours per day which I cannot
don't do at the moment it's just a bit
too much so I'm going to present one
game per round and for this round it
will be the game Carmody Arif at the
time of recording this actually the two
other games are still running I still
decided to do this game as it was very
interesting the two other games at the
moment are running and I don't know how
they will blend so if you if you wanted
to we can very briefly look at the
positions this is the first game that
store on
this is nakamura Kawana here black is is
just somewhat better it's not clear if
we can can really win the game but let's
say let's say yeah I mean it's it's
tricky while suffering from from a bad
bishop here on g2 so interesting to see
how it is going to end the other game
still running is a Arkin game pure on a
job off which is just being drawn okay
it had mustard okay I wanted to say that
this is probably going to end in a draw
and it ended in a draw okay so let's do
to the to the main thing in the in the
next couple of days for for future
rounds I will probably record the video
when the games are all finished so I
will do a very brief some of the other
games of the two games that I'm not
covering in detail and I'll do a
detailed game of the day every time so
Carlsen playing right against Momiji are
often we have a Slav defense on now
semi Slav with the e6 constant playing
ad force what is playing about every
opening so it's not you cannot say it's
a surprise or anything can pretty much
can pretty much play a play any first
move no Bishop g5 yeah usually does that
I mean is 683 is also a mainline of
course but cousin normally allows this
kind of the put Vinick and age six the
the most principled continuations here
for black are now aged 6 and D takes e4
d takes e4 the pure Botvinnik variation
has been under cloud for a while it's
not a field of theory where I can really
em tell you how the current state of
matters is I mean it's for number of
years but winning has a slightly dodgy
mutation and I don't really think this
has changed much as you don't see it
played on the highest level really and
those guys I think they would play it if
they would find some way some in these
complications top players mostly go for
h6 here which can lead to this type of
position with black having the two
bishops and Dwight having better
development and good central control
this is a kind of fair trade let's say
we're often chances are nicely
distributed so black has some chances to
to to win a game or to bid with the
bishops but White has good central play
this is what cards normally does after
age six he does not play the positions
after Bishop age four so much um
this so called and Thomas call gambit
this has been the rage a couple of years
ago or they played it like on and on and
on and it's one of the very few lines
and chess well-liked can combine the
Meuse b5 and g5 earlier not being
totally worse yeah I think the verdict
on this line is still open black seems
to hold his own but it's it's reasonably
unclear yeah in this game Mahmud Yara
played Knight B to d7 which is the third
option really um yeah we know transpose
to a Queens gambit declined and here
white has two choices he can take on d5
leading to them to the exchange
variation the cards but variation as it
is quite often called however here white
is already committed to a 993 which
already has some yeah yes committed the
nine to f3 which means he cannot play
the setup with Bishop to d3 and 92
anymore which feels like a slight
concession however this is a
continuation that I could easily imagine
modernist plain as he likes this kind of
clear structures in this game however he
didn't exchange on you have you played
III after which it is pretty much clear
that black ena will play Queen a5
leading to the so-called Cambridge
Springs variation named after this place
in the US would have been played first
yeah I think more than 100 years ago
about 100 years ago
yeah Queen a5 is very interesting when
it's quite untypical of the Queen's
Gambit as black is initiating a quick
count to play with this pin 90 form
Bishop b4 these are the move that black
is trying to play and it is much more
active in comparison to a move like
Bishop to e7 which really nowadays has a
very old fashion to look to it playing
this sort of passive defense if black
goes for ecigs Knight f6 Bishop e7 which
is the typical classical Queens gambit
declined you normally don't want to have
the pawn on c6 and the knight only 7 so
how do you want to be flexible with
those pieces in getting the modern
interpretation of this opening so Queen
a5 is what normally is played once we
have this position yeah now we've got
this pinning business White has two
options 92 or queen or CD 5 note that
quite often white must be very very
careful here with this with this
situation where the pin if white plays
just for example it's like Bishop to d3
like has ideas like 90 form let's say
Queen c2 and now 95 95 DC for Bishop c4
Queen g5
this is a very typical way to lose a
piece for white which
actually happened to me once in one of
my earliest blitz tournaments 25 years
ago was something like that and I never
had seen the trick before so I was
totally amazed by this and I think the
only happened it happened to me exactly
this one time in this blitz tournament
that that I lost this piece to do to
this this trick okay well in top-level
chess they play 92 here or CD 592 is
considered to be okay for black at the
moment c5 is a bit more testing 95 of
course you want to have this oppression
here not capturing with a pawn
you know counsel played look to see one
this is a relatively recent development
this means in for me yes they mostly
played Queen to d2 him after which the
normal continuation is Bishop before and
then rooks e1 this is perfectly okay for
both sides inside so it's a good line
but black is normally playing is this
some modern interpretation of this line
and it's considered to be M yeah quite
okay for black I guess it's so it's
somewhat shifting all the time between
white being slightly better and black
being okay that just the normal picture
for for main line openings um this rook
c1 moves
however tries to improve on that it's
not a novelty of course it has been
played before the idea is that after
Bishop to b4 now which was not played in
the game but after that why does not go
in Queen d2 into transpose but what will
play a3 and this is an interesting tribe
it's just check allowing a sacrifice
here Queen a3 black can grab a pawn but
this is some this is dangerous
quite quite frankly very often white
will
obtain very serious compensation here
he's got a good central pawn mess and
it's got he's got a good development um
it's a question what white exactly is
playing here Queen d2 is one black very
rarely dares to take the pawn if he does
to do that that's normally this is
inserted then then the capture and now
I'm Queen d2 yeah this has been played
in a game Kramnik playing white against
the sheriff and Moscow 2010 Kramnik and
later won the game white will have a
serious compensation as it's very you
need to be a need to play with very good
nervous as black grabbed her to grab
such a pawn and in this game it was
different mama dro of took one see three
B takes and now Bishop III this is a
different idea of course attacking the
rook Luke c2 must protect c3 and now b6
this is blacks idea he wants to solve
they turn on the problem of the Queens
gambit declined with e6 this Bishop
wants to solve this problem with b6 and
Bishop to a6 okay this was played Bishop
a6 and castles all this is really
logical took only two Queen takes it to
ya know like canceled very natural move
and here we come to a first
theoretically interesting position of
the game this has been played before I
found two games in my my database recent
games some one was from the Tromso World
Cup in 2013 between Wang Hao and Dre F
the Russian Grand Master Dre F is
probably the world's leading expert in
in this line and he also was on the
black site in
this year in the gevalt
de prata open against the plain black
against Victoria Melita one of the top
female players and there they played the
move whoopty won in both games and after
that the movie for I can show you just
briefly to to understand what White's
move is all about Magnus played
differently rook to you one after that
rook e8 e 45 was played and the position
I guess was between equal and a bit more
comfortable for white but nothing
nothing too spectacular but Carlton is
trying to do is he plays before
immediately and this is interesting
because it's not clear that the MOOC t1
is necessary
in this position if he goes before now
which he did the problem is if black now
wants to play e5 he needs to do this
immediately otherwise white will push a
45 in the game here Mahmud Yara played
rook c8 after that there was a five
plate so we have a completely different
pawn structure so if I've would be the
move to play if you want to get this in
and prevent white from advancing more
then white has an interesting option
Bishop to H form it's quite an
interesting way to play Bishop to h4
intends to put it to g3 and increase the
pressure on the e5 pawn and it's a bit
tricky for black here to play because
you don't really want to take on d4
let's say for example rook e8 Bishop to
d3 and now this capture this is
something that you are very reluctant to
do because after C takes the rook on c2
was instantly becoming a very good and
effective piece attacking the the
weakness here and this does not feel
right to this capture you don't want to
play f6 and besides
here that's a very concrete reason not
to play it but it also looks rity chicly
wrong so you may maybe want to cover it
with Bishop d6 also getting this
slightly off side to Bishop into play
yeah after that white plays something
like rook t1 and this makes the piece on
the default feel a bit strange so I
think why does a bit better here after
u5 it just feels slightly better for
wide um he played rook c8 mama dr of did
and after that he v was played so we
have a different pawn structure now and
the interesting thing about this
structure is that council is playing
very directly against blacks um i think
main defect in the position which is the
slightly offside bishop on a3 this
bishop is at the moment completely
without any destination squares it
cannot move anywhere everything's
covered and this can be a bit tricky in
the long run having this offside piece I
think after Queen a4 c4 that's very
logical I'm a Java played rook to b8 and
now look to the one here we here think
we have the first critical position mama
yarn off now played the move c5 which
frankly speaking I don't like it's
probably not bad in terms of yeah pure
pure let's say mathematical evaluation
of the position that's maybe okay but I
don't like to have this bishop offside
and then the long run just just briefly
consider what happened yeah this
happened in the game and now look at
this bishop where does it go where does
they were going I mean it cannot return
to to help in any way in defense with
for the King exam for example or
exchange itself against the bishop on g5
it just stays on a3 and it's doing
much you can put it on before sometimes
to control with d2 but that's it
the spaceship is really not doing much
and it sometimes really even needs them
to be protected by me by the Queen as it
can be attacked for example therefore my
recommendation would be on my suggestion
would be to now retreat it and put it to
evade I'm pretty sure that mamedyarov
considered the move and after only that
place e5 I think we why I didn't do it
is if you consider white playing some
sort of strengthening moves not quite
sure what let's say Hyo that's quite
normal looking after this the problem is
that you sort of want to go to evade but
you cannot and maybe you thought that
given his slightly restricted space I
mean he didn't really know him how to
set up the pieces I mean I think may not
be a it's not that bad actually
intending Knight to c6 at the right
moment but this is maybe what he didn't
like is this type of a position where
those two pieces need to be arranged
differently I still prefer that to the
game I think in the game it wasn't
totally terrible but very tricky to play
we look this way look at this rook t5
was played CD 5 by the way it's not so
convincing because there is the move C 4
and the C pawn get some counter plane
Knight takes e5 looks strong at first
but we get to the end of the slide we
see that white will have very strong
play with the D pawn maybe you don't
appreciate it at first but if you look
at this a bit bit more detail you'll see
that this is very very dangerous if
black plays c4 for example there is the
instantly 67 and black is basically
busted
yeah but see form immediately gives
black very decent counterplay rooty five
carbons move I think it's all it's just
stronger it gets to look on a very
strong square on d5 and of course it
prepares to to just control of the D
file which is the only open file on the
board notice that this bishop is also
very annoyingly placed to always control
d8 so white will get play on the D form
I'm pretty surprised that the the
engines that are checked so give this
position as about equal so this is why
I'm a bit conservative in my assessment
if I mean my first impression would be
that white is already very much more
comfortable but the computer does not
really agree maybe I'm next position is
still sufficiently resilient let's see
what happens we will see what happens
not afraid that's a very normal of
course night going to FA to defend that
can go to b6 the right moment and it was
of course coming under fire on the
default H form very non gaining some
space you can sometimes use the pawn to
provoke more weaknesses you get some air
for the King very goodness h6 is plate
he wants to get rid of the bishop very
understandable drop back to e3 and I
think the next move is not really
fitting into the position manager of
plate 96 and that means I frankly don't
understand very much I think his idea
was what he played in the game maybe
this was the idea I'm sorry well he went
for 97 f5 but it seems that this does
not really seem to Tim seem to work I
like this move actually
try to fight for the D file this uses
the light on f8 as some sort of
protection piece to d7 so you can
actually double on the D fall and fight
for this black is still suffering from
the fact that this is basically not
playing the a3 bishop but it feels like
this should be quite quite tough to
break down he played this as mentioned
but this leads to trouble
Queen d3 and now exactly here we come to
we come to a very critical spot a plate
rook to e6 which was the idea of all
that preparing Knight to e7 it turns out
that this leads to too big trouble
and quite interestingly enough the
computer gives the knight f8s by far the
best move and almost the only playable
move which meets that 96 was not really
working yeah
Luke e6 is what was played and after
that h5 came and on 97 yeah if black now
goes to a fade there is this idea black
is just very very passive now if you
cannot oppose on the D file and white
would simply play Knight a5 Bishop f4
Queen g3 and so on it's just terribly
passive you have lost so much time with
96-98 and the rook is not even
well-placed on e6 yeah he went to his
heaven this was the idea after all
and here comes played the move rook to
d6 and he played it relatively quickly
so we can see here 45:44 about a minute
it turns out that rook t6 wasn't the
best news instead there was the somewhat
yeah it's not weird really am but
surprisingly strong Chan
ta check it seems that this is movies
basically winning on the spot
black mistake Jegs King age 7 and now
there is a key move look at it - yeah
I'm wondering what counts in a mist here
because I mean it's not easy it's not
easy to calculate it but I cannot really
say what exactly the move was that he
missed looked it to it like note-taking
on c4 which looks like the typical order
the move you need to consider let's say
here white has a very strong move and
maybe this is what Carlton didn't didn't
fully calculate white now can play
Bishop takes h6 that that's very strong
very strong with I can take it in
multiple ways so this is the first
checkmate mate in one
ok that was easy King takes checkmate
yep also easy if the politics there is
Queenie 8 and this is not this is not
easy because now you attack here and
it's funny black has absolutely no way
to protect this you can play this but
okay Group D 8 this was the second
threat intending Queen h8 checkmate and
black cannot come with that it's
completely helpless against the mate
this is the the problem white is
combining those threats against f7 with
Queen here or Queen e8 and route d8 and
it turns out that this is absolutely
deadly black has no defense whatsoever
this is the relatively toughest move
after that there is a look d7 and now
his heaviness attacked twice and black
has no way to save that absolutely no
can take here take on a2 and then give
up this night but it's it's just very
much a winning position so card
mr. chance rook t8 was winning he had
prepared Luke d6 beforehand and just
played it quite quickly the bad news for
black is the position is still not good
white still has a very substantial EDM
simply based on the fact that now what
black cannot take on d6 if you take here
this pawn would be just far too strong
you know play - Bishop - before allowing
the Queen to actually move at some at
some point with Queen d3 white was
always white was always attacking a3
from the side so the liability here this
bishop is really the main point in the
game like it's not playing with this
piece and white in a way if you divide
the board into two into two sections
just to do that let's only look at the
Kings are ya just trying to draw a box
here
why just has more pieces on the Kings
side - to play well black will always be
stuck with the a3 bishop and at the
moment there's even the Queen on a for
being slightly off side and this is the
main problem you defend basically being
a piece down on the the critical spot of
the board around the King yeah Bishop b4
yeah rook c1 the strong wants to go to
d1 using this roof on the diva the
bishop on before had this positive
effect not allowing work to detune but
Carlton immediately goes for rook C 1
root D 1 yeah here in this position
Madiha refer playgroup to e8 it's
important of course to note that crenate
- it's not working
check check due to that here just f7 is
attacked and black hair not protected
it's just like that
all pieces are off site here and there
is no piece that can protect f7 white is
just going to take it next move
and there are still tactical ideas that
might even lead to quicker finishes this
is one of them already know this motif
so black cannot take on a two he played
rook e8 to being able to defend is six
later after the capture this pawn is
weakened
it sort of defends it ya know Knight h4
very logical those squares the square
especially is weak the light squares a
weak and white wants to invade him and
there's still the issue of this bishop
like M returns with the Queen a3 pushing
it back to a5 and now look t1 this piece
has absolutely no square white controls
the D file and white invades on g6 all
these things summing up to a very
substantial advantage probably it's not
possible to defend this anymore the
computer is not really giving a totally
winning position for white but it's very
very close because black has absolutely
nothing active he can do and just needs
to defend passively yeah Queen c7 was
played and now councilman 496 here also
f4 what the goons this was my first idea
here just to gain space and long long
term maybe even push g4 you have 4
against 3 here which you can advance and
this wouldn't wouldn't have been bad but
his move I think is just even stronger
he does not play a 4 quickly because
this is a nice diagonal that might be
useful in terms of sacrificing later he
just went for 96 and the big problem is
that black always is in danger to run
into a totally passive position after
Queen d7 and yeah he took now on g6
and that's hard to not take really but
just for argument's sake what happens if
he avoids it yeah the problem is white
is going to invade rather quickly
26:27 it's not so convincing as the
bishop gets in to play Queen d6 is much
stronger as now the Queen trade here's
coming with the tempo on the night and
the night this does not have any good
square let's say to be eight yeah okay
and now I'm going to push him the night
has absolutely nowhere to go widest
totally dominating him yeah I took on g6
and now the Queen recaptured the pawn
recapture looks good at first actually
but black can really take on e5 this is
very important the the big point is that
the move Bishop h6 which at first looks
really strong because taking is failing
miserably made threats here and the rook
hangs black does not need to take
however I can't claim for a [ __ ] f8 and
this in fact it's not totally convincing
for white you sort of yeah you struck a
bit too early here not necessarily you
just took with the Queen now takes and
Queen takes yeah now the rook is hanging
this is hanging the only move that black
hands is Queen f7 absolutely the only
move and now a very strong typical move
for four cards start please Luke t3 sort
of saying okay what are you doing now
this just covers the all-important
square on c3 so the bishop cannot return
into the game and it really asked like
make a move please what are you doing
now and black
like a snow move it's just just very
very sad he played a six now which was
just answered by a for blocking the b5
idea and yeah black when Drew gave eight
there really is not much else if you
take here you find yourself in a in a
really depressing end game white will
just push f4
g4 king over to e form f5 and black has
no moves really he cannot play b5 the
bishop is totally offside and white can
at any time invade on d6 or d7 just
terrible yeah he played rook f8 and now
just G for gaining space you can gain
space here while being walk Queens are
still on the board there's no no problem
black has no account to play whatsoever
yeah it's just like playing a piss-up if
you look at this area you're playing
with an extra bishop this thing is not
playing Queen to e8 was played and now
look to the six attacking on on e6 yeah
I TM 6 is of course attacked twice and
um yeah white will just take it if black
plays a passive move from something like
that well I just take here and win win
easily the endgame is very sad as
already described so mama D Arif decided
to to grab on here for just just take
this but this unfortunately needs to a
very quick defeat can't take c6 King
moves and now not difficult to see
Bishop takes h6 yeah attacking with an
extra piece is always nice and this is
one of those cases this is basically why
it's extra piece you can sacrifice it
here to open up the King position and
gap black can of course not take calf to
this check check
checkmate we have a very quickly
checkmate yeah so what is like going to
do you need to give checks yourself as
why this of course also threatening to
take on g7 and breaking through so let's
say you move like that for example like
we'll just take check and we get
basically the same thing as as seen
before
check the check and now in typical
desperation mode she took on f2 which is
yeah as good as any move you really
don't have any defense it's quite funny
that the computer evaluates this move as
mate in 18 for right now it's depressing
of the computer give such an evaluation
like okay that's easy I'm 18 18 moves
you don't see that okay well you can
easily spot that right wins but not
exactly that the mate in 80 moves yeah
council took it check you know black
black has number checks but white can
always escape by advancing with the king
that's very important jack is checked
now gave it and no to f5 and the
important thing is yeah well you're at
the moment erm you are the piece up and
if black wants to get it back let's say
place Queen takes here check now this is
in fact the easiest even though of
course even the Queen trade yeah just
easily winning
yeah and white will promote one of the
pawns check this is another way to win
as g6 is also deadly yeah me took with
the pawn check and after that yet this
check King here she asked we need 7
check and after this movement yar of
resigned the continuation is King g8 and
now King g6 threatening mate or this and
black has no move really I mean you can
give a check yet I'll just take on age 6
and this young check oops
we'll just promote again one of those
one of those pawns so I'm a very good
start for the world champion with the
Winnie and the white pieces and it was
really I think a very good instructive
game showing how difficult it can be if
you leave one piece offside this Bishop
this is also why I was a bit critical
about the move see fire here as this
basically initiates this situation with
the bishop on only three and my idea was
to play play this back and then play c5
yeah that's always a very tough decision
I mean I'm really sure I mean my name is
yaara was an excellent player he was
aware that this is slightly offside this
piece but he probably thought that it
would irritate white a bit like with
this controlling d2 but it didn't work
out in the end it felt like the burden
on black to play super precisely was
just too high to to to carry and that
the antium went down to the enormous
pressure that white had note that Carson
already could have won
24 here instead of Ruby t6 playing Luke
Janus was winning even quicker but this
was also a very instructive game after
that he just basically kept his active
pieces and let the a3 and the shop
stay off site so a very nice very nice
victory for the world champion to kick
off this tournament all right I hope you
enjoyed the coverage here for the first
round very brief on the other games but
I cannot manage brief summary at the
main desk and this is one game is the
running um
as mentioned for the next rounds I do
quick summaries for the for two games
and one like that in a more detailed
manner thanks for watching